on a december morning
the sun rises over marble bar western
australia
even as it inches over the horizon the
air shimmers with heat
the glowing disc is distorted wavering
in the mirage that clouds the horizon
it's as if it's reflected in some vast
glimmering pool
just out of reach but there's no water
here
in this remote part of the australian
outback water
doesn't last long
the sun ascends through an intensely
blue sky
with no clouds to obscure its piercing
glaze on the landscape below
shadows shorten and all but disappear as
the red rocks bake in its merciless gaze
long rocky ridges extend to the horizon
and hills are cut by sharp valleys
but the agent of their formation is
nowhere to be seen on this hot december
day
the riverbeds are dry only dust flows
along them in the morning breeze
the air is hot heavy and eerily silent
living creatures from insects to the
roaming kangaroos
cower beneath the noonday sun
they seek shade beneath the few sparse
acacias that line the barren river
valleys
it's a tough existence but life clings
on
yet those sun-baked rocks preserve a
record of a very different time
they are granites formed deep in the
earth's crust
long ago volcanic lavas that flowed out
over the surface
and sedimentary sandstones that
accumulated grain by grain
at the bottom of an ancient sea
by themselves the rocks are scarcely
remarkable but their
age is what sets them apart because this
bedrock
shimmering in the heat is 3 billion
years old
this corner of western australia is one
of the oldest remaining slivers of
continental crust from that unbelievably
ancient time
and the rocks tell a remarkable story of
an earth wildly different from today
far removed from the viciously dry and
lifeless landscape in which the rocks
are exposed
the earth at three billion years ago was
a vibrant
barmy water world teeming
with life
a traveler departing marble bar today
embarking on the journey
three billion years into the past would
find themselves
on a truly alien world
three billion years is an inconceivably
large amount of time
it's a thousand times longer than humans
have been on the planet
and five times longer than the rain of
all animals
but if the entire history of the earth
from four and a half billion years ago
to today
were compressed into a single year then
the earth
three billion years ago would be living
through its very own
springtime though still young
in geological terms a lot of time has
already passed on the planet
entering into its second quarter
and while the changes may have been slow
for those first 1.5 billion
years there has still been plenty of
time for planetary
transformation
from the first specks of dust colliding
in a proto-planetary disk
the earth formed a flaming ball of
molten rock
through the hadion it was unsettled
continually battered and bombarded in a
chaotic early solar system
heaving gravitational forces tore its
fragile crust
opening rifts of flowing lava and
shattering the newly formed rock
only time could allow these wounds to
heal as the stray
wandering rocks grew ever fewer in
number
the last few thousand impacts delivered
a precious payload
water and organic molecules
gradually ever obedient to the laws of
thermodynamics
the planet cooled the steamy atmosphere
rained
and rained turning puddles into lakes
lakes into seas
and seas into oceans
bolstered by its watery blanket the
crust solidified into a thick layer of
volcanic rock
meanwhile the planet's interior remained
a scorching
roiling molten mass plumes of liquid
rock billowed upwards for thousands of
kilometers
from the newly formed liquid iron core
up to the base of the volcanic crust
they punched through feeding volcanoes
and shattering
the crust anew
on the shores of these first oceans or
perhaps in the depths
fed by exotic hydrothermal chemistry
organic molecules
form new shapes and new relationships
coincidentally this novel chemistry is
self-sustaining
it promotes the formation and long-term
survival of even more
exotic chemistry and so slowly
incrementally the stage for life is set
at some point a few hundred million
years after the formation of the earth
life begins
and so in a mere 1500 million years
we've seen the planet transformed
from a hellish haideon a racked and
chaotic mess of hot magma and splintered
rock
to the ancient world of the archaean
much of what we take for granted on our
modern planet from plate tectonics to
our protective magnetosphere
from rainforests to the human race
itself
can trace its forebears back to the
archaean
but this ancestral world is still a
foreign place three
billion years removed from the earth
today
standing on the surface of the planet a
traveler from our world would find
themselves in a disconcerting land of
twilight even when the sun stands high
in the sky
the sun itself is scarcely older than
the earth and it too
is in the springtime of its life
even more so as the lifetime of a star
like our sun is typically
10 billion years so at just one and a
half billion years old it's barely
adolescent
this young sun is still ramping up
becoming infinitesimally hotter
and brighter with every passing day
in the archaean it's only two-thirds as
bright
and two-thirds as hot as today
but this faint young sun presents the
planet
with a problem with drastically lower
solar radiation the earth should be
gripped in an unshakable ice age
plunged into a dim coldness akin to the
icy chill that freezes carbon dioxide
solid on the surface of mars
with a faint young sun there's no chance
of water flowing
or of chemistry working to create life
the dim noonday twilight should shine
down
on a snowball planet frozen from pole
to the equator shining icy white
against the blackness of space but it
doesn't
three billion years ago the earth is a
living breathing planet
the rocks at marble bar whisper of
cascading rivers
of thriving life of water cycles and
rock cycles in
full flow this apparent impossibility is
known to scientists as the
faint young sun paradox
that a planet so deprived of warmth can
thrive regardless
but the answer to this paradox isn't so
hard to find
on this very early earth
the planet is saved from a frozen fate
by its atmosphere
unprotected any traveler from today
would soon asphyxiate
unable to breathe the air of their own
planet
like the haitian of one billion years
before the earth is still
deadly to oxygen breathing life
in fact there is no oxygen and
comparatively little nitrogen
both of which make up the majority of
our atmosphere today
instead the air is filled with a heady
combination of carbon dioxide
methane and water vapor a toxic
concoction
to much of life on earth today yet one
which is responsible for keeping the
earth alive
three billion years ago
because these gases belched from
volcanoes and vents all over the planet
have the unique ability to trap heat
they are greenhouse gases allowing the
faint
sun's radiation to pass in but not
letting the reflected radiation escape
by swaddling the globe in this
insulating blanket
holding onto every scrap of heat the sun
produces
the atmosphere keeps the planet warm and
the oceans
liquid
more liquid oceans to evaporate also
means more water vapor in the atmosphere
helping the earth to sustain
its survival blanket over time
and yet it's not as warm as it could be
rich carbon stores in the atmosphere and
enough heat to power chemical reactions
create a dense
photochemical haze just like on saturn's
moon
titan today
this haze lingers as a high level fog
turning the sky's orange and dimming the
sun's light
even more
there are no clear blue summer skies
here
the hottest days only serve to thicken
the haze and cast a sickly orange
gloom over the landscape
this perpetual veil may help the
swaddled earth from becoming too warm
by reducing the sun's thin light when
the planet's surface becomes too steamy
by day the skies have a murky pallor
but by night they come into their own
although the stars may not be visible
the night skies
are bright with another kind of light
the auroras
today green and red curtains of light
are occasionally draped across the north
and south poles
as the powerful solar wind penetrates
the earth's magnetic field
energizing the oxygen and nitrogen in
the atmosphere until it glows
these beautiful auroras are the serene
consequence of our planet's
magnetosphere
repelling and rebuffing the sun's
never-ending particle stream
protecting the surface from the worst of
its effects
although scientists still aren't sure
how it's generated
now or in the past there is evidence
in the rocks that this magnetic shield
has been protecting the earth
for around three and a half billion
years
but the auroras on the archaean earth
would have looked very different to
today's
the color of these ephemeral curtains
depends on the gas that's being harassed
by the solar wind
and because the composition of the
atmosphere was different so too
would the auroral light show differ
instead of green and red created by
energetic oxygen and nitrogen
the skies would shine electric blue
as the carbon dioxide so abundant in
this early atmosphere
is bombarded by the sun's scale
these blue curtains may not be
restricted to the poles either
the planet's magnetosphere is generated
deep within the earth by the flowing of
the liquid iron outer core
around a solid inner core
but three billion years ago the inner
core had not yet
formed the center of the planet was
still too hot for the metal to solidify
despite the crushing pressures
so the liquid in the center was
unconstrained and the magnetic field it
generated
could have been similarly chaotic
geomagnetic poles could shift across the
surface
or there may be no consistent pole at
all
without a single weak point in the
planet's magnetic shield
the solar wind could penetrate the
earth's defenses at any point on the
surface
draping auroras over skies from the
equator
to the pole
but it isn't just the nightly
illuminations that the color shifted
thanks to chemistry beneath the hazy
orange daytime skies
or the rippling blue curtains of night
time the planet's
oceans are tinted a murky green
water itself is colorless or blue tinged
with
depth as the light from the surface is
scattered and dispersed
but in these early oceans the water is
rich
in iron too pumped out of hydrothermal
vents
or delivered by eroding rivers in our
oceans today
iron doesn't stick around long instead
reacting with oxygen from the atmosphere
or being assimilated into living things
but without oxygen in the early
atmosphere the iron can
linger in its dissolved state in the
oceans
there other chemical reactions combine
to transform it into a fine
green rust when this rusty green iron
fills the oceans
it turns them a sickly green
and there's a final chemical clue in the
3 billion year old rocks from western
australia
that helps to paint a picture of an
alien ancient earth
scientists have carefully measured the
abundance of a particular
heavy oxygen isotope which is rare in
our oceans
today this heavier form of oxygen
carrying two extra neutrons in its
nucleus is preferentially locked away
in clay when continental crust is
weathered
modern oceans have little of it and the
rocks that form at the bottom of these
oceans
are correspondingly depleted in heavy
oxygen
but in the three billion year old
crustal rocks
levels of this isotope are boosted
implying that the oceans themselves
contain
lots of this heavy oxygen compared
to its normal form
why should the ratios be so different
over time
scientists think it's because the
archaean earth lacked
continents to absorb the heavy isotope
the 3 billion-year-old earth
was a water world almost entirely
covered by these
bizarre green oceans
we may think that the planet today is
dominated by seas but they cover a mere
70 percent of the surface
imagine instead a smooth sphere of water
peppered with the occasional black
volcanic island or archipelago
but entirely lacking any significant
landmasses
this ancient colour-shifted ocean planet
is our home
but it's discomfortingly alien
and yet beneath the water's surface is a
phenomenon
that is more familiar and as far as we
know
uniquely earthly
descending beneath the surface of the
oceans a time traveler would discover a
hive of activity
albeit microscopic individual life forms
are so small
as to be invisible but the sheer
abundance of life in these archaean
oceans
is visible if you know where to look
and the trick in looking for life here
is to look for the energy
all life needs a supply of energy to
support its metabolic reactions and
these early life forms are no exception
on the slopes of volcanic islands
submerged deep beneath the waves
are systems of hydrothermal vents
linked to the hot magma deep in the
crust by a spidery network of cracks
water circulates and pumps hot
dark metal rich smoke into the green
tinted waters
on the sea floor
the metals and minerals accumulate
around the vents that discourage them
creating towering chimneys that rival an
industrial revolution
skyline and around these chimneys
is life
the walls are coated with a thick but
indistinct fuzz
these are the cities of the archaean
oceans
within that nebulous mass are thousands
millions billions of microbial life
forms
huddling close to the vent feeding off
the reactive sulfur compounds that
settle out
from its billowing smoke
the energy released by breaking down
these compounds is used by these
denizens to keep them alive
and allow them to continually increase
their population
by modern standards this vent is an
inhospitable refuge
dark and scorchingly hot approaching 100
degrees celsius
but to these microbes it's all they know
and all they need
having evolved over millions of years in
this very environment
they are genetically suited in their own
minuscule way
their genes help them withstand the
searing temperatures
and their metabolism craves only the
minerals the vent supplies
without competition or anything larger
to prey upon them their cities
can sprawl colonizing any chimney or
vent
on the ancient sea floor
not only are these microbial colonies
sprawling but they are also
high rise a stratified hierarchy of
slightly differing species
each with their own specialization held
together by a sticky
extracellular goo these microbes form
multicolored layers
wrapped around the hydrothermal chimneys
the lowermost social stratum deals with
the hottest temperatures
and the purest chemical ingredients
ascending through the levels successive
population feed on different chemical
products
each deriving energy from the waste
products of their neighbors
it's a complex interconnected metropolis
writ small around every hydrothermal
vent
it may be bacterial utopia around these
chemical chimneys
but after a few hundred million years of
colonization
it's getting crowded
new life forms continually need to
innovate to find new sources of energy
new niches at the edge of the vent city
other parts of the ocean are less
appealing lacking their dense
concentrations of minerals that these
first microbes rely on for energy
but there is still energy of a different
kind
closer to the water's surface there is
light
the light from the faint sun crosses
interplanetary distances
pierces much diminished through the
photochemical haze that blankets the sky
and penetrates a short distance into the
green cloudy waters
in the shallowest waters the sea floor
is dappled
with dim sunlight
the majority of the vent community would
not be able to make use of or even
notice
this new energy source but a chance
mutation in a microbial suburb
opens up a new metabolic pathway
allowing the use of light instead of
chemistry
for energy these are the very beginnings
of a process that will transform the
living world
photo synthesis
the light is still dim the light-based
metabolism inefficient compared to the
lush abundance at the vents
it's a stumbling start at best but it
allows this new mutated life
to cling on and make anywhere
the light touches its home
the stacked urban planning of the
hydrothermal cities won't work for this
light-based life form though
instead the microbes spread out flat
covering every stable lit surface
they create wide microbial mats still
held together by extracellular glue
but over vast horizontal planes
following the rise and fall
of the shallow sea floor passing waves
and tides wrinkle and tuft them into
spidery patterns
and when a strong current tears the mat
apart itself
heals quickly spreading to cover the
surface
once again
but these rural expanses of microbial
mat
have a weakness
a mere dusting of fine sediment washed
down from the shore
or by a river flood can be fatal to the
entire community
the particles cover the mat sticking to
its binding glue and block the dim light
that the microbes rely on
probably the first communities to be
blighted by this sediment rain
simply died and the new surface later
colonized
but in the quest for survival these
evolving communities
innovated once again learning to sense
the light
through the sandy blanket and growing up
through it
to emerge at the top once again
in this way the light craving microbes
learned to build
upwards layering their mats on top of
successive sediment veils
and always inhabiting the penthouse
suite
this type of structure is known as a
stromatolite and they will become a
defining feature of the microbial
biosphere
they will be found in rocks spanning
billions of years
as domed abandoned skyscrapers entombed
within the sediment
wherever they are found paleontologists
see the echoes of a thriving
seafloor community incredibly on this
ancient
alien world microbial life forms are
carrying out
a niche that they will keep hold of and
spread out from
over the next three billion years
these microbes still exist today
almost unchanged from these original
forms
on this strange multi-coloured hazy
planet
they are setting the stage for all
evolution
to come
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like
subscribe
share and check out the other videos on
the first billion and a half years of
earth's history we've already released
as always let us know what you think in
the comments and we'll see you
next time
you